[Music]
allison's with us in tampa florida hey
allison what's up
hi
pleasure to be speaking with you today
um
i'm calling because
i think i made the worst financial
decision of my life
oh what'd you do
i'm trying to get out of my timeshare oh
you did oh you made a horrible decision
i know
it's legalized fraud
oh
where did you buy a timeshare
like what state yeah or what company
where
i bought it in california in california
what company
it's wealth financial
oh my gosh okay
oh how long ago did you buy it
um 21.
wow just had a weak moment huh
yeah and you know my fiance and i are
just now trying to stay for our first
home so it's really just like
you still owe money on this thing
oh yeah are you kidding me oh yeah no
i'm not kidding and i've i've really
tried i tried everything contacting them
they have reiterated to me many times
they have no deep buyback programs and i
cannot sell or transfer the loan to
anyone until the loan is fully paid off
that's true yeah
yeah
oh
well it's a horrible horrible industry
it's just the worst like i got the two
calls back to back i got a whole life i
got a whole life call and that the next
call has to be about payday lenders i
mean this is like the whole life to
timeshare to payday lenders we're gonna
have to get his blood pressure machine
oh man i'm so sorry i'm healthy yeah
you're just how much do you owe on the
stinking thing
uh about 14k oh my gosh so what'd you do
go out there and stay like for free and
they put you in a room and wouldn't let
you out to your boat or how did that
work
um no we were at an amusement park and
they you know offered us a free vacation
which we got whether or not we wanted to
buy and i told him like my boyfriend at
the time let's you know we're not gonna
do anything um the guy obviously like
was very good at his job um he had made
a lot of promises that i'm realizing
aren't even true like for example if you
book with one other
part
excuse me partners then you get a free
week every time you book with them so we
went ahead and booked
um december then to september come to
realize now we don't get that free week
because they're not with that company
anymore you know things like that so
this is called a fraudulent inducement
yeah he he told you a lie to get you to
buy
so uh here's what you do and i i don't
know if this will work but it's the only
shot you got okay getting out of these
things is very difficult you stepped
into a bear trap
and it got you on the leg and getting
out of it by yourself it's hard it's
very hard and even with help getting out
of it's very hard
we man it's it's it's a nasty filthy
business as you've already discovered
yeah and i have heard of the timeshare
exit team they're gone i don't know they
got run out they got run out of business
by the by
the washington attorney general and
yeah they're horrible i mean it was a
horrible mess they got they did a good
job they got 20 000 people out but they
got run out of business by the time
share business
they uh the legal bills they got sued 60
000 different ways and then they got the
timeshare business got the washington
attorney general after them and it was
just a disaster but for a while that was
a good avenue there is a couple of
groups that are still open doing exits
that are legitimate groups
they're legitimate companies that do
exits but the exit even using one of
these people is very difficult okay so
no guarantees but and they're not it's
not an endorsement i they don't work for
me they don't
you know they don't pay me or anything
like that there's a company called the
newton group
uh and they've actually been helping
some of the timeshare exit customers
that didn't get help because time share
went out of business uh they're trying
to help some of them too but the newton
group
at timesharetruth.com
and uh they've been here to our offices
we've met with them i met with mr newton
and with the several of the lawyers on
his staff they're good people but uh
they will look at you in the face and
say getting out of these things is very
difficult but sometimes they're able to
pull it off
but no promises but that's what i'll
tell you timesharetruth.com
the newton group and i that that's the
best thing i can give you and other than
that just yell at the entire world don't
ever
go to a timeshare presentation under any
circumstances there's no reason there's
no free vacation that's worth putting up
with this crap these are low-class human
beings it's a low-class business it's
nasty it's filthy they lie it's
legalized fraud have i been unclear ken
well dave i was going to ask you to
expound on that thought a little bit i i
don't think you've covered it from
enough angles quite frankly but i don't
want to criticize hate the timeshare
business yeah because they screw people
and i just can't stand when the
consumer's getting messed over it makes
me mad
so what if she can't get out of this
she's gonna write a check she has to pay
14 000 and then she's the proud owner
and then the stupid maintenance fees are
going to go up every year right and then
can she sell it it's like it's like it's
like a disease you can't get rid of oh
that's unfortunate
you can't you they're for sale on ebay
for a dollar nobody wants them
because you get them you get the
maintenance fees and the maintenance
fees go up every year
because these companies are just they're
just straight up scum
it's just awful
i mean they all of them are engaged in
it it's just oh just
uh please please people
you know it's don't never never go into
the tiger cage
that's what i call when you go in for
the sales presentation yeah oh it's like
the tiger has not been fed in four days
yeah but if you can sit in the tiger
cage and not get eaten for two hours
we'll give you a free disney vacation
yeah you know we'll let you go to the
water park for free if you can sit with
the tiger and not get eaten and he's
very hungry though we will tell you and
you sit in there with the tiger don't go
in the tiger they're going to win don't
go in they beat you down what do you
think you are tiger king stay out of
there man it's just don't do it stay
away from the tiger stinking i'll eat
you man it's unbelievable we should do a
hidden camera thing where we put hidden
camera on me and let me be the most
obnoxious question ask her every time
they put some i throw a question back
and we just you could do that i could do
it it would be hysterical yeah be a big
hit dave i go in totally mic'd up you
hidden camera and i'd actually be the
best ramsey personality at being
obnoxious i drive
thank you dave that means a lot that's
like the line from christmas vacation
where wherever he says can you see all
right do you send george campbell in
there no no no it's me are you saying
deloney in there no he would already be
psychoanalyzing he would afford to get
out and be hugging everybody and rachel
would make everybody their friend i mean
you would you or me we're the only two
they're left we have the spiritual gift
of confrontation that's it well no we
just stir up crap that's oh that's what
i mean same thing and so just just
bugging them and driving them nuts to
watch the guy need an antacid
by the time i'm done with him yeah you
know just like totally because here's
what they do what they do is it's high
pressure and they make you feel guilty
don't you take in their freebie don't
you love your family yeah right you
don't love your family well
not apparently as much as you do don't
you love your phone i would thrive in
that environment
i would love that it would be so good to
expose the hybrid as the investigative
report yeah right
oh i may do that oh i don't know there's
a couple of these guys that i owe on one
or two right now i own a couple of licks
back there's a i've bloodied their noses
a bunch of times but i'm not done yet
you're not
off the top ropes i hate those little
jimmy superfly snooker from the welding
it's just they david it's a body slam
because you know who it is they take
advantage of that you know they take
advantage it's old people most of the
time a lot the vast majority of people
get screwed with time shares are the
elderly they load them up from nursing
homes put them on buses and take them to
presentations oh yeah but they also prey
on people who actually are broke and
what they do is they put a twinkle in
their eye and they make them feel like
they can experience what the better half
is is living
the other half i'm telling you it is an
absolute uh manipulation too for for
folks like i wonder what the poor people
are doing yeah it's like hey for a
really good price you can live like
everyone else yeah you see what's going
on there right yeah it's fomo yeah yeah
that yeah for sure oh my gosh yeah and
if you loved your family
you'd spend time with them on vacation
we don't kill trip here but i just want
you to know are you i just wanna know
are you a good father
i just want to know do you love it you
want to go do you really think that
works do you love it how simple-minded
do you think i am that's awful women you
don't love your children
no you look like a man that loves his
children
i mean you have to buy a time share to
prove it